HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE.
TODAY WE HAVE NINE BILLS ON THE
AGENDA WITH THREE BILLS ON
CONSENT.
AS A REMINDER WE LIMIT TESTIMONY
TO TO WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION EACH
WITNESS HAS TWO MINUTES TO
TESTIFY ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
MATT ON BY STATING THEIR NAME
AND AFFILIATION [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WE TAKE OUR OUR BILLS BY SIGNED
IN ORDER AND THAT DOCTOR PAM.
WE'VE GOT YOUR FIRST.
ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
[inaudible]
FIVE TWELVE WELCOME.
WE'LL BE STARTING OUT AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AS WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SHALL
BEGIN YES PLEASE THANK THANK YOU
SO MUCH MEDICARE MEMBERS -- BUT
THANK YOU FOR THE UPDATE PRESENT
TO SB FIVE TWELVE WHICH TAKES
THE FIRST CRITICAL STEP IN
CREATING A LONG TERM SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS OUR L. TSS BENEFIT
FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE NEED FOR THIS LEGISLATION
THIS THE BENEFIT IS URGENT
ALMOST EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE WHO
ARE EITHER OLDER ADULTS ARE
INDIVIDUALS WITH PHYSICAL MENTAL
DISABILITIES CURRENTLY LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS POPULATION WILL GROW
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE NEXT
DECADE BUT UNFORTUNATELY MANY
CALIFORNIANS LACK ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE L. TSS SERVICES.
WHAT TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
ARE NOT ADEQUATELY COVERED BY
MEDICARE AND MOST CALIFORNIANS
CANNOT AFFORD TO PURCHASE
PRIVATE LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
AND I THINK WE KNOW THAT THAT
MARKET ALSO?
IS QUITE TROUBLED.
PAYING FOR OUT OUT OF POCKET FOR
L. TSS IS VERY EXPENSIVE AND
CREATES A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
SOCIAL BURDEN.
SO WHAT IS THE ALTERNATIVE WHILE
CALIFORNIANS MUST SPEND DOWN
THROUGH LIFE SAVINGS TO BECOME
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE NOW.
AND TOO OFTEN THIS IS THE
PRIMARY MEANS BY WHICH OLDER
ADULTS AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES CURRENTLY RECEIVE
ACCESS TO PAY LONG TERM SUPPORT
SERVICES.
MEDI CAL IS A CRITICAL SAFETY
NET BUT THE SYSTEM IS
OVERBURDENED AS WE KNOW AS WE GO
THROUGH OUR BUDGET PROCESS.
INDIVIDUALS SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
IMPOVERISH THEMSELVES AND SPENT
THROUGH THEIR LIFE SAVINGS AND
OUR CHILDREN'S INHERITANCE OR TO
FOREGO WORKING WHICH IS THE
OTHER THING THAT HAPPENS IS THAT --
YOU NEED THE SERVICES AND IF YOU
GO WORK YOU ACTUALLY MAKE TOO
MUCH MONEY AND THAT YOU CAN'T
AFFORD YOUR CERTAIN SERVICES SO
YOU FOR GO WORKING AND
GENERATING EARNED INCOME IN
ORDER TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SERVICES.
THESE THEY NEED TO LIVE
INDEPENDENT HIGH QUALITY LIVES.
SO THIS LEGISLATION IS TO CREATE
A FRAMEWORK FOR THE MANAGEMENT
OF LONG TERM SERVICES SUPPORTS.
BENEFITS THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
SPECIFICALLY SB FIVE TWELVE
CREATES THE INFRASTRUCTURE
MODELED AFTER THE CALCIUM OR
SECURE CHOICE PROGRAM FOR WHEN
CALIFORNIA'S RATE THE DESIGN AND
FINANCE THIS NEW BENEFIT.
INDEED THIS LEGISLATION
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
AGING AND DISABILITY ALLIANCE
WHICH REPRESENTS TWENTY
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM BELT YES A STAKEHOLDERS.
WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD NOW TO
PUT THESE CRITICAL PIT PLATE
PIECES IN PLACE SO WE CAN
CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD WITH
BENEFIT AND FINANCING DESIGN.
SOME PLEASED TO HAVE THE
TESTIFYING SUPPORT -- TEST MAY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION
FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
AND THE A. R. P. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF WITNESSES THANK YOU
DOCTOR PAN FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA MALES I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS WE
ARE A MEMBERSHIP ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S INDEPENDENT LIVING
NETWORK.
AND CURRENTLY REPRESENT TWENTY
TWO OF THE TWENTY EIGHT CENTERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS ARE
ADVOCACY AND SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS RUN BY AND FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES THEY'RE
NOT PLACES YOU LIVE.
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
PROVIDE A WIDE VARIETY OF
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE OF ALL TYPES
OF DISABILITIES ACROSS THE
LIFESPAN.
I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING AND BEING A TAX
CONTRIBUTING MEMBER OF MY
COMMUNITY FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
I WAS BORN WITH MY DISABILITY
AND RELIED ON SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME AND MEDICAID
SERVICES UNTIL I BECAME WHAT IS
REFERRED TO AS GAINFULLY
EMPLOYED BY THIS.
BY THE SYSTEM.
TRANSITIONING FROM PUBLIC
BENEFITS TO KNOW SUPPORT WAS AND
REMAINS ONE OF THE HUGEST
DECISIONS OF MY LIFE.
I RELIED ON MEDICAID SERVICES
EVERY TIME I BROKE A BONE
FRACTURE NEED SURGERY A NEW
WHEEL CHAIR PHYSICAL THERAPY A
WALKER CRUTCHES AND SO MANY
OTHER HEALTH CARE NECESSITIES.
MY EYES WERE WIDE OPEN WHEN I
MADE THE DECISION TO LEAVE MY
SAFETY NET BEHIND AND TAKE A JOB.
ALTHOUGH I WOULD NEVER ALTHOUGH
I WOULD FOR EVERY NEED LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS IN A
VARIETY OF WAYS I ALSO WANTED TO
GIVE SOCIETY GIVE TO SOCIETY.
AND BE PAID FOR MY WORK.
I HAVE MANAGED TO GET.
BY FOR A WHILE WITHOUT L. TSS
MEDICAID SERVICES SPECIFICALLY
BUT AS I CONTINUE TO AGE WITH A
DISABILITY I FIND MYSELF WITH
LESS AND LESS SAVINGS.
AND MORE OUT OF POCKET EL TSS
EXPENSES.
I CONSIDER MY COMPANY'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLAN TO BE PRETTY
DECENT.
HOWEVER WITH THAT I AM STILL
PAYING ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR OUT OF POCKET FOR
L. TSS.
SOMETIMES IT'S DURABLE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY A
WHOLE MODIFICATION OR DOMESTIC
SERVICES THAT I NEED IN MY HOME.
IT ALL ADDS UP AND MAKES THOSE
OF US WHO ARE WORKING HARD TO
MAINTAIN EMPLOYMENT AND SAY FAR
FUTURES.
IT FEELS AS THOUGH WERE BARELY
HOLDING ON TO A CLIFF FOR
SURVIVAL.
MY ORGANIZATION AND I ASK YOU
FOR JUST SUPPORTER ON SB FIVE
ONE TWO BECAUSE IT'S TIME TO
CREATE AN L. D. S. THAT'S
FRAMEWORK.
THAT ACCOUNTS FOR BOTH AGING AND
DISABILITY COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO
THE MIDDLE CLASS CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE AN ACCIDENT AWAY FROM
BEING IN THE SAME SITUATION AS
ME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JENNIFER
VERDUGO MINNESOTA SEAT STATE
DIRECTOR FOR A A. R. P.
REPRESENTING OUR THREE POINT
THREE MILLION CALIFORNIA MEMBERS.
AIR P. IS ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA AGING AND DISABILITY
ALLIANCE WHICH IS SPONSORING SB.
FIVE TWELVE SB FIVE TWELVE IS A
PRIORITY FOR A A RP AND THE
SIMPLE REASON IS THIS.
I'LL TIAS HAS COST MORE THAN
WHAT MOST CALIFORNIANS CAN
AFFORD.
AIR P. RESEARCH FROM TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SHOWS THAT
DESPITE A MEDIAN INCOME FOR
OLDER DON'T HOUSEHOLDS OF FIFTY
THOUSAND THE AVERAGE ANNUAL COST
OF A NURSING HOME IS DOUBLE THAT.
A HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN THOUSAND
FOR A PRIVATE ROOM AND NINETY
SEVEN THOUSAND FOR SHARED ROOM.
HIRING A HOME HEALTH AIDE TO
PROVIDE CARE AT HOME FOR THIRTY
HOURS A WEEK IS THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND A YEAR.
SO IT'S EASY TO SEE HOW MOST
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES SIMPLY CAN'T
AFFORD THIS.
AND EVEN FEWER CAN AFFORD LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE IN FACT ONLY
5% OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
PURCHASED THE POLICY.
TODAY I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
TO OUR OF OUR OUR OF OUR
VOLUNTEERS WHO HAVE SHARED THEIR
STORIES AND SEVERAL COMMITTEES
THIS YEAR AND SB.
FIVE TWELVE THE REASON CAN RADO
COME MARINO AND DAVID FEINSTEIN
CAN'T BE HERE TODAY WAS BECAUSE
THERE CARE GIVING FOR THEIR
LOVED ONES THIS WEEK.
DAVID IS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WITH HIS MOTHER.
THANK IN RADO IS HELPING TO
MANAGE CARE GIVING FOR ONE OF
MANY RELATIVES HE HELPS TO CARE.
FOR FAMILY CAREGIVERS LIKENED
RADO AND DAVID SPEND AN AVERAGE
OF SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
OUT OF OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES
CARING FOR THEIR LOVED ONES.
AIR P. IS ALSO FOUND THAT THOSE
CARING FOR SOMEONE WITH
ALZHEIMERS OR DEMENTIA CAN SPEND
NEARLY ELEVEN THOUSAND A YEAR
I'M LEFT ONCE.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS THE
REALITY FOR MANY.
DAVID'S MOTHER IS NINETY FOUR
AND LIVING IN A MEMORY FACILITY
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE COST OF CARE IS A LITTLE
OVER NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH.
BUT THE MONEY MONTHLY INCOME SHE
RECEIVED THEIR A SMALL VETERANS
PENSION AND SOCIAL SECURITY DOES
NOT EVEN COVER HALF THE CARE.
AS AN ONLY CHILD DAVID FEELS
RESPONSIBLE TO PAY THE REMAINING
BALANCE HE'S USING HIS OWN
RETIREMENT SAVINGS TO PAY THE
REMAINDER OF THE BILL.
THIS REDUCING WHAT HE AND HIS
WIFE WILL HAVE SHOULD THEY NEED
THEIR OWN CARE IN THE FUTURE.
FOR CAN RADO.
COMING FROM A LARGE FAMILY CARE
GIVING IS A FAMILY AFFAIR.
AT ANY ONE TIME HE HAS A WIFE
AND THEIR SIBLINGS ARE IN THE
THROES OF CARE GIVING FOR AN
AGING OR DISABLED FAMILY MEMBER.
THEY'VE SPENT THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS.
OF OUT OF POCKET -- TO CARE FOR
THEIR PARENTS.
THEY'VE TAKEN TIME OFF OF WORK
TO CARE FOR THEIR LOVED ONES AND
HAVE NAVIGATED THE DISJOINTED
FRAGMENTED PATCHWORK OF ALL TSS
SERVICES.
AS CAN RADO HAS TOLD US MANY
TIMES THIS IS WHAT FAMILIES DO.
WE CARE FOR OUR LOVED ONES BUT
IT'S ALSO BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY OTHER CHOICE.
BOTH DAVID IN COLORADO ENVISION
A TIME WHEN FAMILIES LIKE THEIRS
WILL HAVE OPTIONS WHEN OTHERS
WON'T HAVE TO SPEND AS MUCH OUT
OF POCKET AS THEY DID.
AND WON'T HAVE TO TAKE TIME OFF
OF WORK.
DEALING WITH LOST WAGES AND LOST
FUTURE SOCIAL SECURITY AND COME.
THIS IS WHY A R. P. URGES YOU TO
PASS SB FIVE TWELVE FOR FAMILIES
LIKE CAN RATOS AND DAVID'S.
AND FOR THE NEARLY FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION FAMILY CARE GIVERS
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
.
I AM MY NAME MOVE THE THE BID
LOW.
EIN BIER RENDON THEN
[inaudible]
LIAM WHOOPED.
THE NEW MAN THE BILL MOVES AND
THEN THE WORK.
OF THE BEGINNING OF THE WORLD.
ONE NEW THE LIVE PHONE DIEM.
AND ONE YEAR OF THE DONE DO.
M. V. V. N..
WEARING.
AN GRAHAM BLOOM THERE WITH THEM
THEY NEED TO OWN THEM.
I AM YOU IN THE WORLD -- VERVE
BE BRAVE DUO [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK.
MY NAME IS SASHA BITTNER ON
BEHALF OF HAND IN HAND THE
DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS NETWORK.
ALSO SPEAKING AS A LIFELONG USER
OF HOME CARE AND FINALLY AS A
DAUGHTER OF AGING PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS WHO NEED IT I AM
HERE IN SUPPORT SB FIVE TWELVE
THANK YOU.
I'M BRIAN GORMAN I'M HERE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
RETIRED AMERICANS -- HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CRISTINA BOSS HAMILTON
WITH YOU W. -- WE'RE MEMBER OF
KEITA THE GROUP SPONSORING THE
BILL.
THE ONLY COMMENT I HAVE IS THAT
WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME IN THIS
BUILDING TALKING ABOUT POVERTY
AND HOW TO ALLEVIATE POVERTY IN
TRYING TO CRAFT POLICIES TO DO
SO.
WE SPEND VIRTUALLY NONE OF THAT
TIME TALKING ABOUT HOW THIS IS
CREATING POVERTY AND HOW THIS IS
RESULTING IN HOMELESSNESS.
ALL WE HAVE TO EXPAND THIS
DISCUSSION IN THIS BUILDING TO
INCLUDE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND SENIORS WERE BEING
IMPOVERISHED BECAUSE THEY CAN'T.
AFFORD TO PAY FOR THESE SERVICES
AND THE POLICY THAT EXIST
CURRENTLY IS ACTUALLY
INCENTIVIZING POVERTY BUT FOR
SOME REASON IT GETS NO ATTENTION
M. THIS IS CHANGING SO THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR YOU'VE BEEN A
CHAMPION DOCTOR PAN ALSO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR THE REST OF THE
REST OF THE WITNESSES COMING UP
IN SUPPORT.
I ALSO TO GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION ONLY MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS TIFFANY RIGHT WITH
THAT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT A PROBLEM NUMBER OF KATE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROCKS SAND GOAL
REPRESENTING SIX BEDS DOT ORG IS
AN ASSOCIATION OF SIX BEDS ARE
FEWER.
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY AND DEVELOPMENT
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI SENATOR MADAM CHAIR CASEY
O'CONNOR BEHALF THE STATE
TREASURER FIONA MALL ALSO WHO
HOUSES THE CAL SAVERS PROGRAM
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU BEFORE THE NEXT
WITNESS I WANT TO PAUSE.
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH QUORUM
PLEASE.
RAY S. PRESENT MATHIS
[inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
TôI [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN STONE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A QUORUM YES
THE NEXT WITNESS CAN CONTINUE
NOW.
I REMEMBER BURKE IS HOME WHERE.
DEREK OF CALIFORNIA AND USE THE
AND THE USED TO BE COALITION AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WITH THE TIME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON NICOLE DOLL SKI
WITH THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE TWELVE AND
ALSO A PROUD MEMBER OF KATE.
THANK YOU.
JEFF TORTILLA AN ADVOCATE
[inaudible]
HOW?
DOG FIGHT.
AND A NUMBER OF OTHER COALITIONS.
SUPPORTING THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
STILL VERY SWEET THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF THE BLIND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RPG ALSO WITH CAL PACE
WE REPRESENT THE PROGRAMS OF ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY
SERVING ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE
HUNDRED FOR ALL SENIORS
STATEWIDE.
STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL VERY
PROUD MEMBER OF CARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I JUST DID A TOUR OF
ONE OF YOUR FACILITIES IN SAN
BERNADINO.
VERY IMPRESSIVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRED HAMPTON
REPRESENTING LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA.
NOT FOR PROFIT PROVIDERS A
SENIOR FOR WILL HOUSING CARE AND
SERVICES -- ACROSS THE STATE
ALSO A PROUD MEMBER OF KID IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU -- CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
MEMBER KATE INSTRUCTS PART THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
KRISTIN HEYMAN WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT DAY
SERVICES AND ALSO A MEMBER KATIE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CAROL SO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING ALSO A
MEMBER OF KEITA INSTRUCTS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YOU'RE COMING UP.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE TO THE COMMITTEE.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YES DOCTOR CHOI.
THANK YOU A CHE ARE AN INCENTIVE
PAN -- I THINK THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT -- TOPIC LONG TERM
CARE SERVICES.
OR PEOPLE WHO SELL UNABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES IN THE
PARTICULARLY UP AGING POPULATION --
I'M GETTING THEY ARE -- THEY
ALREADY.
MY MOTHER IS -- OF BEING TAKEN
CARE OF NINETY SIX YEARS OLD
LADY.
AND THE MANY FEMINISTS ARE
FACING THIS A CRITICAL ISSUE --
YOUR BILL IS -- PROPOSING TO
ESTABLISH.
A CALIFORNIA LONG TERM SERVICES
SUPPORT.
OF BENEFITS OF WAR.
BUT IT DOESN'T MENTION.
WHAT IT WILL DO EXACTLY AND OFF
WITH A FUNDING WILL COME FROM?
AND ON HOW THE BENEFICIARY OF
ANY FISHERIES WILL BE DEFINED TO
HOLD THE BENEFITING AND HOW MUCH.
A TO ASSIST SUCH TRUST -- SO
THIS IS A MORE LIKE A SOCIAL
SECURITY KIND OF THING BUT THE
SOURCE OF SECURITY AMOUNT IS NOT
ENOUGH -- SHOULD NOT TO LEAVE
AND THE WITH THE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE MINIMUMS SO MY MODEM
MONEY OR WHAT WILL IT REALLY
TAKE CARE OF THE NEEDY PEOPLE
WERE.
IN ON A TO BE IN THE INSTITUTION
FOR THE A TOTAL CARE.
DO YOU HAVE BEEN EXPOSED BUT
BECAUSE DOT ORG ON ALICE'S SAYS
THAT THE U. APPEAL IS THAT
ACTING IS ARE NOT WELL PREPARED.
AND THE NO MENTION ABOUT FUNDING
CAN YOU ELABORATE IF YOU TO HELP.
ONE SO FIRST OF ALL I WOULD
MENTION THAT THE ABOUT THE
FUNDING FOR THE BILL ITSELF IS
ACTUALLY A PART OF THE THE
BUDGET THAT IS NOW BEEN ENACTED
IN.
NOW IN PLACE IT'S AN OUT SINCE
IT'S JULY -- BUT THE WHAT WE
NEED TO DO WHAT THE BILL DOES
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS ACTUALLY.
DOES VERY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
RAISE THIS FIGURE THAT OUT RIGHT.
WE KNOW THAT -- WE ACTUALLY AT A
HEARING OF THE SENATE BUT SAVE
COMMITTEE.
NUMBER THREE AND I KNOW THAT --
YOU KNOW.
THAT -- ALSO DID BEEN HEARINGS
AND SO FORTH EXAMINATIONS AND
SIMPLY SIDES WELL KNOWING THAT
WE HAVE AN AGING POPULATION.
WE HAVE ALSO WITH PEOPLE.
WITH DISABILITIES AND THAT -- WE
THE ONLY INFRASTRUCTURE READ WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW IS ESSENTIALLY
MEDI CAL SO WE ARE PAYING.
FOR THESE SERVICES THROUGH
MEDICARE HOW WHAT WE DO THE TELL
PEOPLE YOU KNOW.
YOU HAVE TO SPEND DOWN ALL YOUR
MONEY -- IF YOU'RE A PERSON WITH
DISABILITIES YOU CAN'T WORK
ESSENTIALLY BECAUSE YOU
BASICALLY.
MAKE IF YOU MAKE TOO MUCH MONEY
YOU FALL OUT RIGHT SO WE'RE
WE'VE HAVE A SYSTEM WHERE WE'RE
TRAPPING PEOPLE INTO -- INTO
POVERTY ESSENTIALLY IN ORDER TO
GET TO THE SIDE TO SERVICES AND
AND FRANKLY YOU KNOW FROM A FROM
A STATE BUDGETARY STANDPOINT --
THAT'S ALSO AN ISSUE TOO BECAUSE
WE BAY IS THAT THE WISEST USE OF
OUR MONEY IS BASICALLY SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT HAPPENS IS WE
WANT EVERYONE TO SPEND DOWN INTO
POVERTY AND THEN TRAP THEM THERE
AND THEN THAT'S WHEN THEY CAN
ACCESS THE SERVICES BECAUSE WE
ARE PAYING. FOR LONG TERM
SUPPORT SERVICES.
SO WHAT WE WANT TO THINK ABOUT
IS THAT OKAY WE WILL CREATE A
FRAMEWORK TO SAY ALL RIGHT WELL
WHAT CAN WE TRY TO DO -- IN. TO
SET UP A PROGRAM YOU YOU MADE
THE AND WE MENTIONED CAL SAVERS
YOU MENTIONED SOCIAL SECURITY
BUT LET ME WE HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT HOW DO WE CREATE A
STRUCTURE KNOWING THAT WE HAVE
AN AGING POPULATION WE HAVE.
FOUR PEOPLE THIS THE ONLY PEOPLE
DISABILITIES HAVE THE POTENTIAL
TO BE ABLE TO LEAD ACTIVE LIVES
AND ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTE.
IN MANY WAYS INCLUDING
ECONOMICALLY TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND SHOULD WE TRY TO CREATE
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES AND AND THAT
I THINK THAT WHAT WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT AND SO HIGH AND HOW
WHAT WOULD THAT TAKE.
RIGHT WHAT WITH THAT TAKES YOU
POSE THAT QUESTION AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT AND
THAT'S WAY AM.
PLEASED TO HAVE THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE.
US IN SUPPORT BECAUSE WE WHILE
WORKING AND AND AND DO THAT
ACTUARIAL ANALYSIS AND SAY WHAT
WOULD IT TAKE BECAUSE YOU
MENTIONED WE HAVE A PRIVATE LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE -- THAT IS
NOT WORKING RIGHT IT'S WE HAVE A
THE THE THE THE THAT COVERAGE IS
NOT REALLY THAT AVAILABLE IT'S
EXPENSIVE -- THERE'S A LOT OF
ADVERSE SELECTION ISSUES THAT
ARE INVOLVED BECAUSE OF THE
EXPENSE SO WE NEED TO THINK.
ABOUT WHAT HOW CAN WE GO ABOUT
CREATING THE INFRASTRUCTURE SO
THAT MIDDLE CLASS CALIFORNIANS.
HAVE ANOTHER OPTION OTHER THAN
SPENDING DOWN THE POVERTY THE
OTHER THING IS IS THAT
OFTENTIMES THE RULES THAT WE
CREATE NELLY TO TRAP PEOPLE
POVERTY SOMETIMES EVEN PUSH THEM
TOWARD INSTITUTIONALIZATION
WHICH IS ACTUALLY VERY EXPENSIVE
AND BY THE WAY WE'RE BEARING THE
BILL OF THAT.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS --
BECAUSE THEY GO IN MEDI CAL AND
THEN THAT'S THE ONLY CHOICE
PEOPLE HALF AND SO -- YEAH WE
WANT TO THINK ABOUT.
CAN WE THINK IT THINK ABOUT HOW
WE WE THEN BE ABLE TO USE
WHATEVER FUNDING WE WE ESTABLISH.
TO DE BE ABLE TO USE IT MORE
WISELY IN A WAY THAT LETS PEOPLE
BETTER.
LIVE IN PLACE AN AGING PLACE AND
AND SO FORTH AS WELL SO BUT
THOSE THINGS HAVE TO BE FIGURED
OUT AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS
URGENT BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
POPULATION IS GETTING OLDER.
WE CAN SEE THE DEMOGRAPHIC
CHANGE BUT YET WE HAVEN'T
FIGURED THIS QUESTION OUT YET.
AND SO THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL THE BELLS LIKE WE'RE
RUNNING OUT OF TIME TO FIGURE IT
OUT I MEAN WE CAN.
EVENTUALLY WE WERE GOING TO HAVE
TO FIGURE IT OUT OTHERWISE WILL
HAPPEN IS IS THAT.
IF WE LEAVE THINGS THE WAY THEY
ARE THE FALL PLAN IS IS THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE MORE MORE
PEOPLE AND THEY'RE DOING IT
RIGHT NOW SPENDING DOWN THE
POVERTY.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT AND
THEN ON A MEDICARE PROGRAM AND
WE'RE FORGETTING HOW TO DO THE
MEDICAL BUDGET EACH YEAR AND SO
WE'VE I JUST AS A MEDIC COW.
AND AT DAHLE TELL USE THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO WE HAD TO WORK OUT
THIS WHOLE NEW DEAL WITH THE
COUNTIES AND SO FORTH TO FIGURE
OUT I JUST US AND WE DID A
HEARING HE SAID THE WHOLE IF WE
JUST.
DELIVERED SERVICES THE WAY THEY
ARE.
JUST THE WAY THAT THE CURRENT
LEVEL THAT WE'RE PROVIDING THEM.
WE ARE GOING TO YOU KNOW THE
JUST BECAUSE THE DEMOGRAPHIC
CHANGES.
THE THE EXPENSE TO MAINTAIN
SERVICE AT THE CURRENT LEVEL
ACTUALLY IS GOING TO GROW FASTER
NO GDP IN OUR STATE.
BECAUSE OF THE AGING POPULATION
MARIE SO.
IF WE DON'T TRY TO CAN ADDRESS
THIS THING [inaudible]
NOW.
WE WILL WE WILL BE SUFFERING THE
IMPACT OF THAT -- ACTUALLY NOT
TOO MANY YEARS IN THE FUTURE SO
THAT'S WHY I'M DOING THIS BILL
THIS IS THAT'S WHY THAT
COALITION BEHIND IT WE NEED TO
CREATE MORE OPTIONS. TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES THAT ALSO ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO AT
MAINTAINED OR MIDDLE CLASS
STATUS BE ALLOW PEOPLE
DISABILITIES TO BE ABLE TO BE
ACTIVE IN THE WORK FORCE AND SO
FORTH.
AND INSTEAD OF SAYING THAT THE
ONLY OPTION IS SPEND DOWN TO
MEDI CAL OUR STAY IN THE MEDICAL
SYSTEM.
THANK YOU.
CAN I HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
ON THAT THANK YOU UP FULL
EXPLAINING.
BASICALLY -- TO MAKE IT SHORT --
YOU STATED THAT THE CURRENT US
THAT UP THE PROBLEM -- AND THIS
L. TSS WOULD FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM?
DO YOU HAVE A ANY -- YOU'LL SOON --
IDEA THAT DO YOU YOU YOU CAN
SUGGEST TO AS DSS.
WHEN IS FORMED BECAUSE OF?
ONCE WE CREATE THE SUCH OF
BUREAUCRACY.
IN ALL PROPER CF THE BUREAUCRACY.
IS THIS IS THE PROBLEM THAT WE
DON'T HAVE -- SUCH A BUREAUCRACY
WE HAVE THIS KIND OF PROBLEM.
IN ALL.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THIS WILL
JUST OF KEEP ON ADDING THE
PROBLEM TO THE CITIZENS THAT AND
THE WE MAY END UP AND TO THOSE.
IN THE SAME IN OUR PLACE TO
WHERE WE ARE AT THE SO DO YOU
HAVE BEEN IS UP IN A IF I MAY
MAKE MY IDEA WHAT'S WHAT'S
SHOULD BE CLEAR IS THAT THIS
SETS UP THE CALIFORNIA LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS BENEFITS
BOARD.
THE CALIFORNIA LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS BENEFIT
TRUST FUND AND THE CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM SERVICES A SPORTS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE SO IT'S
SETTING UP THE STRUCTURE.
WOOD AND PROVIDES FOR THE
FLEXIBILITY BUT DOCTOR PAT IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD AS A SHORT
RESPONSE YEAH AND SO FOR FIRST
OF BY THE WAY I SHOULD ALSO
MENTION THAT -- WE PREVIOUSLY
ALSO FUNDED A STUDY TO LOOK AT
THE NEED AND DEMAND FOR LONG
TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORT SO
THAT WE DIDN'T COUPLE YEARS AGO --
PRIOR BUDGET USING CHEST SO
WE'RE COLLECTING DATA BUT I
WOULD ALSO SAY IS IS THAT --
LOOK WE'VE [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
WE WE CURRENTLY ARE MEDI CAL
SYSTEM WE ACTUALLY WE ACTUALLY
TRIED DEPRIVE IT'S A TOTALLY
PRIVATE SECTOR APPROACH THAT'S
THE THE LONG TERMS.
YEAH LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
THAT'S NOT WORKING THAT MARKET
YOU KNOW INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE
BANDING THAT MARKET THAT DIDN'T
WORK.
SO -- BUT WE HAVE THAT IN THE
NEED AND SO THIS IS AN EFFORT TO
LOOK AT HOW CAN WE GO ABOUT
DOING THAT YEAH YOU'RE RIGHT
PRIDE MAY INVOLVE SOCIALIZING
SOME OF THE COSTS BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT.
I WILL ALSO POINT OUT THAT --
THAT -- WE ACTUALLY WHAT PEOPLE
GET OLDER THE ALTERNATIVE IS NOT
REALLY FOR THAT YEAH WE WANT
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO AGE AND BE
ABLE TO LEAD LIVES OF DIGNITY
AND IF THEY NEEDS THOSE SUPPORTS
TO BE ABLE.
TO HAVE SOME OPTIONS TO GET THEM
THE CAVS SOME ALTERNATIVES TO
GET THOSE SUPPORTS.
THAT'D THE SIDE FROM SPENDING
DOWN THE POVERTY AND GOING ON
MEDI CAL WHICH IS BY THE WAY
WHICH WE'RE ALSO PAYING.
FOR IS A PUBLIC ENTITY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
RIGHT BUT I AM REALLY ENCOURAGED
BY THE CREATION OF THIS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE -- BRINGING IN THE
CONSUMERS A CARE GIVERS
PROVIDERS IN THE ADVOCATES I
THINK WHEN WE HEAR HEAR FROM THE
EXPERTS.
I THINK DOCTOR CHOI YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT ON
POINT WE NEED TO TO KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THE ISSUE IS AND THEN
FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO
SOLVE IT.
BECAUSE WE'RE PAYING FOR IT
ALREADY.
AND SO.
MAKING SURE THAT AT WE'RE
ALREADY TALKING ABOUT THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING WERE SETTING THIS
ALL UP AND THIS IS ANOTHER
IMPORTANT STEP SO I DO THANK YOU
FOR FOR PROVIDING THIS.
I DO WANT TO CONFIRM THAT YOU
HAVE ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS YES
VERY GOOD THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE THIRTY EIGHT IN THE IN THE
ANALYSIS.
AT THE OKAY THERE THERE.
THANK YOU AND IN THE THE THE
THEY WERE TECHNICAL CORRECTIONS
STOCKARD CHANNING.
OTHER I HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE A
DISRESPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE SACRAL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES HI RES I
MATHIS.
ARAMBULA.
CHOI CHOICE I FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
GIPSON MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
EYES STONE STONE AYE.
WE HAVE FOUR VOTES THE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
SENATOR PORTANTINO.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
.
ONE SEVEN TWO YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK YOU ARE MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SB ONE SEVEN TO HAS --
MULTIPLE PARTS ARE WITHIN THE
BILL ALL RELATING TO INSURING
FIREARMS ARE PROPERLY LOCKED AND
STORED SECTION ONE ESTABLISHES
THE KEEP OUR SENIOR SAFE.
ACTIVE WOULD REQUIRE REGULATIONS
AND PROCEDURES FOR FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION WITHIN A RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITY.
WHEN THE FACILITY ALLOWS
RESIDENTS HAVE GUNS AND
AMMUNITION THE BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE FACILITIES TO ACCEPT
AMMUNITION OR FIREARMS BUT IT IF
THEY CHOOSE TO ALLOW?
WE WANT PROCEDURES IN PLACE TO
PROTECT THE RESIDENTS AND STAFF
THIS IS A VULNERABLE POPULATION
AND AS SUCH WE WANT TO HAVE
THESE LAYERS OF PROTECTION -- WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND STAKEHOLDERS TO CREATE A
SYSTEM.
THAT PROTECTS RESIDENTS STAFF
AND VISITORS FOR ENSURING
ULTIMATE SAFETY AND I HAVE --
MONICA MILLER ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA -- ADVOCATES FOR A
REFORM WITH ME TODAY.
THANK YOU.
HI.
THE MADAM CHAIR MONICA MILLER
REPRESENTING CONSUMER ADVOCATES
FOR RCMP REFORM IN AN RCF EITHER
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY.
THEY WERE CREATED IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX AND THE INTENDED AS
MUCH OF THE SIX BUT MODEL WHERE
YOU HAVE A LOVED.
ONE THAT YOU CAN NO LONGER CARE
FOR HOME BUT YOU WANT TO NOT
NECESSARILY INSTITUTIONALIZE
THEM.
SO THESE ARE FACILITIES WHERE
IT'S IN SOMEONE'S HOME THEIR
CARE GIVERS FAMILY VISITS.
EXTRATERRESTRIAL ON WHEN MEMBERS
GO INTO THESE FACILITIES THEY
ARE ON THIS VISIT IT'S
RESIDENTIAL BASED.
SO THEY CAN TAKE WHATEVER THEY
WANT WITH THEM AS LONG AS THE
FACILITY ALLOWS IT TO THEY CAN'T
TAKE A FIREARMS OR AMMUNITION
ETCETERA.
THAT THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO THIS MEASURE JUST SIMPLY SAYS
AMONG OTHER THINGS THAT IFIN
FACT THERE ARE FIRE ARMS ON THE
PREMISES THAT THEY ARE PROPERLY
STORED IN LOCKED IN THAT THERE'S
NOTIFICATION. TO THAT EFFECT ON
WHAT HAPPENS IS WE'VE DONE SOME
CARRY.
ON REQUESTS ALLEN PULLED FROM
THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
WHEN THEY DO THEIR CHECKS ON THE
FACILITIES TO MAKE SURE THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THEIR
LICENSURE.
THAT ON THEY WALK IN AND THERE'S
A GUN SITTING AT A DESK AND
AMMUNITION EITHER RIGHT NEXT TO
IT OR IN IN THAT IN THAT KIND AT
THAT POINT.
AND IT'S DANGEROUS TO CHILDREN
TO FAMILY MEMBERS TO CARE GIVERS
TO THE SOCIAL WORKERS SO IT'S
SIMPLY JUST STANDARDIZING THAT
AND ENSURING THAT THERE IS AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY ARE
PROPERLY LOCKED IN STORE JUST
LIKE YOU WOULD HAVE IN YOUR OWN
HOME -- AT ANY QUESTIONS BUT WE
URGE AN AYE VOTE TODAY AND THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I DO WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE
THAT SB ONE SEVENTY TWO WAS
REFERRED TO THIS COMMITTEE
BECAUSE OF THE PIECE OF THE BILL
PERTAINING TO OUR SEE A FEES.
THIS BILL WAS ALREADY HEARD IN
THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE ON JUNE TWENTY FIFTH
WITH THE ADDITIONAL ELEMENTS OF
THIS BILL.
THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF THIS
COMMITTEE'S JURISDICTION WERE
ALSO CONSIDERED.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS IN THIS
COMMITTEE SHOULD BE LIMITED TO
THE JURISDICTION.
OF THIS COMMITTEE WHICH IN THIS
CASE IS A LICENSURE AND
REGULATION OF RC A FEES OR THE
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES.
ALL RIGHTS LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
THE BEST PORTANTINO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE CHAIRED AN
EXCELLENT JOB CAPITALIZING THE
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THIS CALL ROLL YOUR
FIRST.
AND A SECOND IT'S COLD WORLD.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES HI RES I
MATHIS.
ARAMBULA CHOI.
CHOI NO FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN ICE
STONE.
STONE HI.
WE HAVE THREE TO ONE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
START CALLING [inaudible]
SENATOR DOLE.
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS SO ITEM NUMBER
SIX SHALL WE BEGIN WITH THAT.
ONE YES.
SP.
FOUR THIRTY SIX GOOD AFTERNOON
MR MEMBERS.
ARE SP FOUR THREE SIX WOULD
DEFINE A FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS.
AS HE RECOGNIZED ENTITIES UNDER
STATE LAW TO PREVENT TO HELP
PREVENT CHILD ABUSE AND FURTHER
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
MODELS OF CARING CALIFORNIA.
NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF CALIFORNIA
DOLE TYPE EXPERIENCE AT LEAST
ONE ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCE.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT EARLY
CHILDHOOD ADVERT.
ADVERSITIES NEGATIVELY IMPACT A
CHILD'S DEVELOPMENTAL
FUNCTIONING INCREASE SEEN RISK
OF SOCIAL EMOTIONAL ACADEMIC.
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS.
THE IMPACTS OF CHILD ABUSE CAN
RIPPLE THROUGHOUT OUR SOCIETY
WITH ABUSE COST IN OUR NATION A
STAGGERING TWO HUNDRED MILLION
EVERY SINGLE DAY AND FUNDING
ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASED.
UTILIZATION OF CHILD WELFARE
CALVET CALIFORNIA F. FORESEES
ARE FOCUSED ON STRENGTHENING
FAMILIES BUILDING COMMUNITIES
AND MITIGATING RISK FACTORS
WHICH LEAD TO ABUSE.
SB FOUR THREE SIX SIX TO
FORMALIZE FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS IN STATUTE FORMALLY
RECOGNIZING THEIR INVOLVEMENT.
AND PROGRAMMATIC ACTIVITIES
ALREADY UNDER WAY WITHIN THE
CHURCH OFFICE OF CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION TODAY I HAVE WITH ME
MY THAT HE THOUGHT.
ROAD CHECK EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CENTER LEFT A MILLION FRESNO.
AND JOSE MANUEL GOT ABOUT IT CUT
BY -- A PARENT THE HAS TWO
CHILDREN AND TO THE LEFT MILLION
FRESNO.
ALRIGHT FIRST WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BEFORE.
THIRTY SIX MY NAME IS MARGARITA
ROACH UP FROM CENTRAL OFFER ME
THE ADVOCACY SERVICES IN FRESNO
CALIFORNIA.
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO
CENTRAL UP FOR ME TO ADVOCACY
SERVICES HAVE HAS HELPED.
THOUSANDS OF FRESNO COUNTY
RESIDENTS YOUR LIFE CHANGING
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT.
THE PROVIDE SUPPORT RESOURCES
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION.
WE SERVE MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
FAMILIES ANNUALLY AND REACH MORE
THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THROUGH
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
PRESENTATIONS WORKSHOPS SPECIAL
EVENTS AND MULTI ETHNIC MEDIA.
SB FOUR THIRTY SIX WHAT FORMING
ALIVE.
IF I RECEIVED LIKE CENTRAL OF A
MEDIA AS A KEY DELIVERY NETWORK
OF SERVICES.
AND AS A CONDUIT TO
STRENGTHENING FAMILIES VIçT
FAMILY CENTER COMMUNITY BASED.
AND CULTURALLY SENSITIVE
SERVICES.
SB FOUR THIRTY SIX WOULD HELP IN
CONTINUING OUR WORK IN OFFERING
A BROAD RANGE OF PROGRAMS.
DESIGNED TO ASSESS CRIME VICTIM
SUPPORT FAMILIES AND CHILDREN.
PROMOTE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
ENCOURAGE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND
MORE.
AT CENTRAL FOR ME THAT WE OFFER
PROGRAMS LIKE FAMILIES TOGETHER.
A FIFTEEN WEEK PARENTING
EDUCATION CLASS.
THAT ENCOURAGES THE GENERAL WELL
BEING OF FAMILIES ADDRESSING
ISSUES SUCH AS PERSONAL SAFETY
AND PREVENTION OF CHILD ABUSE BY
TEACHING FAMILIES.
ABOUT APPROPRIATE PARENTING
PRACTICES.
THE EFFECT OF CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT AND HOW TO ESTABLISH AND
MAINTAIN HEALTHY.
NETWORKS.
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
APPROACH TO CHILD SAFETY.
AND WELL AND WELL BEING IS
PREDOMINATELY REACTIVE.
NOT PREVENTIVE.
UNLIKE TRIAL WILL FOR SYSTEMS
ACROSS THE NATION WHO HAVE
LEVERAGE A VARIETY OF STRATEGIES.
AND REGULATORY FRAMEWORKS TO
FIND AND SUSTAIN THEIR LOCAL
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS
[inaudible]
S. SUCCESS.
AND SUSTAIN THEIR LOCAL FAMILY
RESOURCES AT SUCCESSFUL UPSTREAM
EARLY THE EARLY INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION ORGANIZATIONS.
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT MANY
CALIFORNIA FOR SEES HAVE
HISTORICALLY.
AND CONTINUE TO APPLY AD HOC
FUNDING OFTEN PURE.
PIECING TOGETHER.
BLENDED STRATEGIES THAT THAT
PUTS THROUGH PRIVATE DONATIONS
AND COUNTY DOLLARS.
INCLUDING GENERAL FUNDS OR
DECLINING FIRST FIVE FUNDING.
A KEY REASON.
FRC IS ARE NOT RECOGNIZED
ENTITIES UNDER STATE LAW. FOR
THIS REASON WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ITS BEFORE THIRTY
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
HELLO HELLO MY NAME IS MONEY SO
I'M GONNA JUST LATEST OFFER FOR
CENTER MINISTER TARA AND I WILL
BE TRANSLATE INFO SOMEONE WILL.
HAVE A YOU.
MEMBER NAY THE WHAT THAT IS.
MOST OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT GIVE THAT IF
THAT'S JUST.
REPORT TO ME THAT BUT A LOT OF
SAID CUTTING ME UP FOR YOU ALEX
LOVE FIELD IT'S A BAY.
WHAT THE THING THE STATE?
DO YOU WANT TO TAKE THE OTHER
MICROPHONE.
THERE THAT WE DON'T TAKE IT AWAY
FOR A LET HIM HAVE HIS OWN.
LIKE IN BECAUSE TO ME GROW PHONE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK ABOUT MY SUPPORT FOR AS
BEFORE.
THREE SIX THE NUMBERS WILL
THURMOND WILL PROVIDE YOU'LL.
SO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BY MIDDAY US YOUR AIM WAS.
I AM ONE WILL IMPLEMENT THEY
WILL SCUTTLED TO THESE WITH
INFILL OF AMELIA.
THIS IS MY LITTLE THAT WOULD
MEAN THE CO.
TWO THEN GLOBAL FECA EQUAL TO
YOU THAT IS SIMPLE ENOUGH AMELIA
IS HE'LL.
BUT IF IT EAGLE FOR THE VISUALLY
GUIDED BY A PLATE THAN THEY HAD
LEFT BUT TO PUT THIS THAT THE
SEEKER THE HELP OF CENTER LEFT
FAMILIA.
I HAVE BEEN REFERRED TO LEGAL
SERVICES IN ORDER TO HAVE THE
PARENTAL AUTHORITY OF MY
DAUGHTERS.
SINCE RECEIVING CUSTODY OF MY
DAUGHTER'S CENTER OF A MEDIA HAS
ASSISTED ME IN A PLANE AND TO
PUBLIC SERVICES SUCH AS COVERAGE
AND MEDICAL.
THE MUD FOR THE MEET THE FEEL TO
IT BUT THE BOTTLE.
THE COMPLETE THAT'LL BODIES
PARAMETER DID BY THIS FORMALLY
BRAHMA. FOR IMMEDIATE WHO NEED
US GIVE ME YOUR LOW UP.
UP IN THERE BUT BECAUSE THE THE
ANSWER THE ABOUT.
IT THAT WITH THEIR THE HEAD OF
THE COMBINED YELLS THE LOUDEST
HE MUST.
BE A AT THEN THE AS LITTLE
PULLED UP FOR YOU BUT UP BY THIS
GIVE ME LOCAL MARBLE OUTPUTTING
SEE HAS.
MISSING YOUR LAKEPORT DANCE YOU
HAVE THAT.
THE GROOM BY THE FIELD PM FOR
THE CALIPARI.
ECO MOST THAT EFFECT BOTH OF
THEM THINK THAT.
IT'LL BUT I'M NOT MAD AT YOU
THAT'LL IF THE YELLOW.
ALMOST SET MAHOOD PAPA.
IT WILL LOOK AT THE END OF THOSE
GREAT THE SCHERING QUALITY
FAMILY TIME.
AND HOW TO SHOW AFFECTION
TOWARDS MY DAUGHTERS THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE HELPED ME AND
TAUGHT ME HOW TO BE A BETTER
PERSON. ONE OF ABLE ABLE CRIMEAN
TO FORMAL CONSENT UP ON MEDIA IS
THE POOR OUT MONTH.
A PLEASE WILL BE ADDED YEP WE
GOT OUT OF BY THE SKIN FEEL
LONELY IT.
BUT A SEVERAL OF AMELIA YET BOLD
LEGAL A RADICAL WHAT THE SPOTTED
THE LOCAL MONEY THAT.
GAVE WHERE THEY WILL BE TAPPED
ALL THE PROGRAM MUST KILL
PRESSING.
BECAUSE OF MY INVOLVEMENT WITH
CENTER LOVE FAMILIA AND IT'S
PROGRAMS I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
GUIDE AND SUPPORT OF THE PARENTS.
I HAVE BEEN A LEADER FOR CENTER
LET FAMILIA I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
TALK TO THE PARENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY WHO CAN USE OTHER
PROGRAMS THEY OFFER.
THE CENTER OF A MEDIA FOR
INSTEAD OF A MEAL AT THE POOR I
MUST.
IF POSSIBLE LAKE IN NORTH FOR
THE YEAH.
Là BUT THE PEOPLE TO STUDY YOU
SEE THAT.
NO WE'RE UP IN THE THE OLD ONE
SEVEN WHAT BUT BY.
GO MOBILE THAT WHEN MICHAEL
MONEY THAT WHAT IS THAT A FILM
FEEL SHOP FOR YOU WHAT ARE THE
HE LEFT FEEL IT'S CIVIC WHAT THE
BANK THE FAITH THAT THE WITHOUT
CENTER FAMILIA AND ITS PROGRAMS
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT WOULD NOT
HAVE THE PARENTAL AUTHORITY.
OF MY DAUGHTERS I WHEN I HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY RESOURCE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU KATHY SAID KNOWING
WHAT THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ALEX TO CAPRI ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WHEN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE'S QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
PROMOTIONS SECOND OME TRUTH
OTHER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU FOR ALL
OF YOUR WORK AND OF THANK YOU TO
OUR WITNESSES HERE TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THE STATE ROOM.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES HI RES I
MATHIS ARAMBULA.
CHOI.
CHOI I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
EYES STONE.
STONE AYE.
WE HAVE FOUR TWO ZERO I WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR IN JULY 2% ON YOUR NEXT
BILL.
IT'S ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB.
FOUR NINETY SO.
I'D LIKE TO START OFF.
BY A STEP IN THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
SB FOUR NINETY WILL HELP PREVENT
HUNGER AMONG LOW INCOME PEOPLE
WHO ARE ELDERLY OR DISABLED AND
IN RECEIPT OF SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME BY REQUIRING THE
COUNTY TOOK STAINED FROM
COLLECTING.
AND OVER ISSUE CALL FRESH
BENEFIT FROM THEM IF THE OVER
ISSUANCE WAS CAUSED BY COUNTY
CARE.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM KNOWN AS
CONFESSION HERE IN THE STATE IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT ANTI HUNGER
PROGRAM IN THE COUNTRY.
THAT HELPS LOW INCOME PEOPLE WHO
ARE ELDERLY OR DISABLED WITH THE
FOOD BASKET TO HELP THEM MEET
THEIR BASIC FOOD NEEDS.
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY FOR
EXAMPLE THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES
ARE AIDED BY SNAPPING ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR CAL FIRST BENEFITS
WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE PER MONTH HAVING
BEEN HELPED BY FOOD BANK FOR
FOOD DISTRIBUTIONS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THE SP
FOUR NINETY IS ALSO IN LINE WITH
RECENT FEDERAL CHANGES WHICH A
LINE THE CALPERS ELIGIBILITY A
TRIFLED WITH FEDERAL SNAPPED
ELIGIBILITY TRASH HOLDS.
WITHOUT AS BEFORE NINETY
CALIFORNIANS WITH PRECARIOUS
HEALTH NEEDS ARE LIKELY TO GO
HUNGRY MORE FREQUENTLY UNTIL.
THEY'RE OVER PAYMENT IS RESOLVED
SO I ASK YOU MEMBERS TO SUPPORT
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
AND TODAY I HAVE WITH ME JESSICA
BARTH LOW WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER OF ON LAW AND POVERTY.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS THANK
YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
DESK ABOUT THE WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
AT AS WAS MENTIONED THAT COVERS
PROGRAM IS ONE OF THE MOST IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT AND I HAVE A
PROGRAM IN THE STATE.
OF OVER FOUR MILLION PEOPLE TURN
TO THE PROGRAM TO HELP WITH
THEIR FOOD IS FOOD NEEDS IN A
PREVENT HUNGER THE BENEFIT GIVES
IS A FOOD BENEFIT CAN ONLY BE
USED FOR FOOD.
AND IT'S A DOLLAR FORTY THREE
PER MEAL ON AVERAGE.
BEFORE JUNE OF THIS YEAR PEOPLE
WHO ARE ELDERLY OR DISABLED AND
RECEIVING SSI INCOME WERE
INELIGIBLE.
FOR EIGHT UNDER THE CALPERS
PROGRAM.
BECAUSE OF ACTION TAKEN BY THIS
LEGISLATURE IN PEOPLE LEADERSHIP
M. RIGHT HERE IN THIS ROOM.
PEOPLE BEGAN TO RECEIVE CAL
FRESH THROUGHOUT THE STATE IT IS
LIFE CHANGING FOR THEM.
BEFORE JUNE THOUGH WHEN PEOPLE
APPLIED FOR BENEFITS AND THEY
HAD SSI.
THEY SOMETIMES WERE ERRANT LEE
GIVEN BENEFITS AND IT WASN'T
THEIR FAULT THEY AT THE WORKER
MISTOOK THE INCOME THEY RECEIVED.
FOR AS SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION BENEFITS OR S.
STI OR SOME OTHER FORM OF
BENEFITS FROM THE SOCIAL
SECURITY ADMINISTRATION.
WHEN THAT HAPPENED THE THE
SENIORS?
OR PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WERE
FORCED TO PAY BACK THE MONEY
THEY RECEIVED IN CASH.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE INCOMES BELOW
70% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LINE
AND SO -- OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE
HEARD FROM MANY DIFFERENT PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY ABOUT HOW HARD
IT'S BEEN.
AT THEY CAN'T GET FOOD BENEFITS
THEY HAVE CASH BENEFITS BELOW
70% OF THE POVERTY LINE.
AND NOW THEY HAVE TO PAY BACK
FOR AN ERROR THAT THEY DIDN'T
MAKE.
OF THE COUNTIES DON'T WANNA
COLLECTED AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T WANT US TO
ANSWER THIS BILL BASICALLY SAYS
IF THE FEDS ARE ASKING US TO
COLLECT THE MONEY -- THAT WAS
THERE IN THE GIVEN TO THEM THAT
WE WON'T -- IT'S THAT SIMPLE
IT'S A GREAT BILL WE'RE SO PROUD
TO BE A SPONSOR AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PATRICK MORE TERROR WITH FIGHT
CRIME MISSION READINESS AND
READY NATION AND MORE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR -- I'LL
HAVE A CONTEST ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU KATHY SAID KNOWING
WHAT THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
LIDDY SANTOS SEIU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THE PATTERSON CALIFORNIA FOOD
POLICY ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ENTER SHANE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS AND
CALIFORNIA'S PRESS ASSIGNED
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
SILVER EARRINGS THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF THE BLIND IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACKI ALONG WITH
AND HELP LIVE IN CALIFORNIA --
THE GRAYSON TO INSTRUCT PART
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HE ME DEAR LOWER RIVER CITY FOOD
BANK IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WE'RE BUSY SO JUST WANT SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING THEM LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SENATOR I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD -- I
THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS
THAT WE'VE GONE THIS LONG WHERE
WHEN THE STATE'S SCREWS IT UP.
ARE PEOPLE I NEED PAY -- I'D
LIKE TO ADD ON AS A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR WITH YOU ON THIS MOVING
FORWARD.
I WOULD LIKE THANK YOU.
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS VERY
GOOD SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
OUR MOTION AND A SECOND PLEASE
TAKE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES HI RES I
MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I'D
CHOI.
CHOI ON A FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN EYES
STONE.
STONE I CURRENT VOTE IS SIX TWO
ZERO WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF
BEFORE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
AND ALL RIGHT WE GET A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT ITEMS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT IS ON SB TO TWENTY EIGHT SP.
TO NINETY EIGHT AND SB SIX
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE TAKE THE
WRONG RAY S. HI RES I AM MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I'D
CHOI.
CHOICE HI FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN EYES
STONE.
STONE AYE. SIX TWO ZERO WE WILL
ALSO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
OKAY
ALRIGHT LET'S ADD ON THIS
MOMENT.
FILE ITEM ONE SB ONE SEVENTY TWO
THE CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TO ONE
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
CURRENT VOTE FOR THE TWO FILE
ITEM SIX SB FOUR THIRTY SIX
CURRENT VOTE IS FOR TWO ZERO
MATHIS.
MATHIS I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO FILE ITEM SEVEN SB.
FOUR NINETY CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO FILE ITEM AIDS SB
FIVE TWELVE CURRENT VOTE FOR TWO
ZERO MATHIS.
MATHIS I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I A
CURRENT VOTE
.
SIX TO ZERO SENATOR WILK WELL
COME.
ON ITEM NUMBER TWO SB.
TWO NINETEEN WE HAVE A MOTION --
AT A SECOND.
GREAT MAY BEGIN.
WHEN YOU ARE READY?
WELL THE INTEREST OF TIME I'M
I'M NOT HAS BEEN A LOT OF IT BUT
I I DO HAVE. TWO PEOPLE HERE TO
TESTIFY SO I THINK I'D LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER THEM SO HAVE LUCY
CARTER WITH THE YOUTH LAWCENTER.
AND THEN SHE CAN INTRODUCE OUR
OTHER GAS ACTUALLY LET'S START
WITH QUITE A HI EVERYONE -- MY
NAME IS QUITE A JOHNSON I'M A
FIRST GENERATION STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY CAN YOU HEAR ME.
OF STUDYING MOLECULAR AND CELL
BIOLOGY WITH AN EMPHASIS IN
GENETICS.
AND A MINOR REASON LAW.
SO CURRENTLY A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
ME I WORK IN A RESEARCH LAB.
I SETTLE VASCULAR SURGEON I KIND
OF DESIGN PROP PROGRAMS AND
EVENTS FOR A CAMPUS ORG I HELP
SPEARHEAD CALLED BLACK CUTIES
FOR BLACK WE'RE INTRANSIGENCE AT
CAL.
ALSO RAN A CLOTHING BRAND
COMPANY FOR INNER CITY YOUTH
CALL JENNY YANG WHICH STANDS FOR
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT AT WORK AND
USE ADVOCATES AND NAVIGATING
GROWTH.
AND DO A LOT OF ART AND I CAN
THE LIST GOES ON AND I KNOW IT
SOUNDS LIKE A LOT BUT I DON'T
SEE IT TO IMPRESS ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM -- YOU SEE MANY PEOPLE ARE
USUALLY IMPRESS WHICH IS GREAT
BUT I'M NOT AS RARE AS MANY
BELIEVE -- I BELIEVE ALL MY
FOSTER SISTERS AND BROTHERS ARE
CAPABLE OF MASTERING THEIR MANY
TALENTS IF GRANTED AND PRESENTED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT.
AND I ALL A LOT OF MY GREATEST
POLICY QUALITIES AS A PERSON TO
THE EXTRA CURRICULAR ACTIVITIES
I WAS BLESSED TO BE A PART OF
AND I'M EVEN MORE THANKFUL FOR
THE FOSTER PARENTS I'VE HAD THAT
PUT IN THEIR OWN EFFORTS AND
FUNDING TO SUPPORT.
MY LOVE FOR ART MUSIC AND
SCIENCE I SERIOUSLY DON'T KNOW
WHERE I WOULD BE IF THEY DIDN'T
DECIDE TO STEP UP AND GO THE
EXTRA MILE -- AND HERE'S WHERE I
BECOME INEVITABLE INEVITABLY
PESSIMISTIC -- BECAUSE MY
BROTHER AND MY YOUNGER BROTHER
HE WASN'T AFFORDED THE SAME
QUALITY CARE IS ME.
A SOME OF THE FOSTER PARENTS HE
WAS UNDER THE CARE OF DID THE
BARE MINIMUM -- HE LOVES SPORTS
BUT HEARD NO SO MANY TIMES WHEN
IT CAME TO ASK.
ASKING FOR MONEY US SUPPORT INTO
GETTING INTO CAMPS AND GETTING
FOOTBALL GEAR BECAUSE THE COST.
AND FOREVER WHATEVER REASON THE
FOSTER PARENTS DID NOT PROVIDE
HELP IN GETTING HIM INTO
ANYTHING HE REALLY WANTS TO GET
INTO.
AND THAT INCLUDES WRESTLING AND
BOXING.
SO.
UNFORTUNATELY HE FOUND HIS
BELONGING ELSEWHERE IN THE
STREETS WHERE HE COULD PUT THAT
ENERGY AND CURIOSITY TO USE --
AN IDOL I BELIEVE THAT HE'S.
SMARTER OR YOU KNOW JUST AS
SMART AS ME AND YET HIS STORY
HAS A DIFFERENT OUTCOME DUE. TO
THE DIFFERENCE IN CARE THAT HE
RECEIVED -- LIKE I MENTIONED
BEFORE I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
EXTRA MILES TAKEN ON BEHALF OF
SOME OF MY CARE TAKERS BUT IT
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE A TO LOOK
THAT A YOUTH IS PLACE WITH
SOMEONE WHO IS CAPABLE OF
A CHILD PURSUE THEIR INCHES -- I
FEEL LIKE ALL FOSTER PARENTS
SHOULD HAVE THE SUPPORT IN THIS
AREA SO THAT THE QUALITY OF THAT
CHILD'S UPBRINGING IS IT LEFT UP
TO CHANCE.
AS I THINK BACK OUT ALL THE
OUTLETS THAT HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO
MY GREATEST QUALITIES ALSO
REMEMBER THE LASTING FRIENDSHIPS
AND SKILLS OF COMMUNICATION AND
DRIVE FOR ADVOCACY THAT I'VE
TAKEN AWAY FROM THOSE
EXPERIENCES.
NAY REALLY GROUNDS ME AND
STABILIZES AND YOU STILL TO THIS
DAY.
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW
FAR AWAY I MOVE AWAY.
THOSE THINGS WILL ALWAYS MOVE
WITH ME ITS STABILITY I CAN TAKE
WITH ME ANYWHERE I GO.
AND HONESTLY IS REALLY A SMALL
PRICE TO PAY FOR SUCH A LONG
TERM EFFECTS THAT TRULY SHAPE
THE CHILD AND INSTILL WITH THEM
THE DRIVE TO DEVELOP THEIR
IDENTITY THEIR PASSION AND THEIR
FRIENDSHIPS.
IT SURE HELPED ME.
AND IF WE STOP LEAVING IT UP TO
CHANCE THAT A CHILD RECEIVES
HELPING GETTING TO PARTICIPATE
IN EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES OR
THINGS THAT THEY LOVE TO DO.
JUST IMAGINE HOW MANY CHILDREN
WILL GET A FIGHTING CHANCE.
TO TAKE CONTROL OF THEIR OWN
DESTINY.
I LIKE TO BELIEVE THAT I'M NOT
RARE.
JUST A PRODUCT OF RARE QUALITY
OF BRINGING.
ANDACCOUNTABILITY IS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE WHEN YOU HAVE
CONTROL AND SO FOR THESE REASONS
ACTUALLY TO SUPPORT AS BE. TWO
ONE NINE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
YES MY NAME IS LUCY SELFIE THE
CARTER IN THE POLICY ADVOCATE
WITH THE YOUTH LAWCENTER AS YOU
HEARD FROM MS JOHNSON
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES ARE
VITAL.
THEY CAN BE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN GOOD AND BAD OUTCOMES
FOR FOSTER YOUTH THEY CAN MAKE
ALL THE DIFFERENCE IN GIVING
FOSTER YOUTH THE SKILLS
CONNECTIONS AND STABILITY.
THAT WILL TAKE THEM BEYOND
FOSTER CARE TWO HEALTHY AND
PRODUCTIVE ADULTHOOD.
THE RESEARCH FULLY SUPPORTS MISS
JOHNSON STORY STUDIES SHOW THAT
PARTICIPATION IN EXTRACURRICULAR
IS HELP YOUNG PEOPLE DEVELOP
RESILIENCE.
ACCOMPLISH IMPORTANT
DEVELOPMENTAL TASKS AND
COUNTERACT THE HARMFUL EFFECTS
OF TRAUMA.
IT RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS A
PARTICIPATION IN EXTRACURRICULAR
IS IMPROVED ACADEMIC OUTCOMES IT
ALSO REDUCES YOUTH PARTICIPATION
IN RISKY BEHAVIORS.
EXTRACURRICULAR SO IMPORTANT FOR
ALL YOUNG PEOPLE BUT THEY'RE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FOR
FOSTER YOUTH WHO FACE TRAUMA
INSTABILITY IN LOSS OF SUPPORT
OF CONNECTIONS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY AS MISS
JOHNSON POINTED OUT THEY'RE NOT
AVAILABLE FROM MOST FOSTER YOUTH.
IT'S THE LUCK OF THE DRAW
WHETHER THEY HAPPEN TO BE IN A
COUNTY THAT IS FIGURED OUT SOME
EXTRA FUNDING FOR THIS.
OR HAPPEN TO BE IN A FAMILY THAT
CAN AFFORD IT.
AND WE KNOW THAT EXTRA
CURRICULAR AREN'T CHEAP.
ALL OF US WHO ARE PARENTS OR
CAREGIVERS IN THE ROOM.
BALLET LESSONS SAT PREP MUSICAL
INSTRUMENTS THAT COST REAL MONEY
AND FOSTER PARENTS DON'T HAVE
THIS MONEY.
SO SENATE BILL TWO ONE NINE WILL
ALLOW FOR COUNTIES TO PILOT
PROVIDING GRANTS TO FOSTER YOUTH
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
SO THAT IT'S NOT LEFT UP TO
CHANCE WHETHER THESE YOUTH CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THESE ACTIVITIES.
IT'S OUR HOPE THAT SB TWO ONE
NINE WILL LEAD TO STATEWIDE
SUPPORT DOWN THE ROAD SO THAT
ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER YOUTH
CAN PARTICIPATE IN
EXTRACURRICULAR.
CALIFORNIA LAWMAN DATES NORMALCY
FOR ITS FOSTER YOUTH.
THIS BILL HELPS ENSURE THAT THE
STATE'S FOSTER YOUTH GET TO
EXPERIENCE THIS VITAL PART OF A
NORMAL CHILDHOOD.
WE FOR CLOSELY WITH THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT ON SOME OF
THE BILL AMENDMENTS THAT WILL
FURTHER STREAMLINED THE GRANT
PROCESS SO THAT FOSTER YOUTH IN
THE PILOT COUNTIES CAN GET THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE TO ENGAGE IN THESE
ACTIVITIES.
SO FOR THESE REASONS I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
IN MY HASTE TO GO THROUGH I'D I
DO WANT TO TAKE YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR FINE WORK
AND WE DO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU THAT WAS GOING TO BE
MY QUESTION.
I REALIZE THAT WE SAID.
HI I SAY THAT SO VERY GOOD OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL FOR
THE REASONS STATED BY OUR
ELOQUENT WITNESS THANK YOU.
YEAH WOULD THAT YOUR WITNESS WAS
ELOQUENT.
WHAT?
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MIGHT THE GUERRERO
REPRESENTED LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THANK
THE AUTHOR SENATOR WILK FOR
CHAMPIONING THIS ISSUE AND THE
WITNESS DOING A GREAT JOB AND
GOOD LUCK IN WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I REMIND.
THE REST OF THE WITNESSES.
I WANT TO JUST THE NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
I HAVE A CONTRACT ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BUT AS HERNANDEZ WITH
CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTION
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JOSE CANAS ALL FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH IN STRONG SUPPORT ON I'M
ALSO PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONNECTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CRISTINA PART OF A CALIFORNIA
CONNECTION IS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
LIVVIE SANTOS AS HE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU MADE IT.
JEFF TORTILLA PUBLIC ADVOCATE.
ALSO FORMER FIFTY YEARS AGO
FIFTY PROGRAM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
YES MISTER LANDER GREAT BUILD LE
VEHICLE AUTHOR.
WE WILL ADD YOU.
MR GIPSON DITTO. FOR FAMILY YOU
HAVE TO BE CO AUTHOR.
OTHER WHAT AT COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
SAYING NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER STRICTLY ASPEN
ABOUT.
IT THANK YOU SO MUCH PLEASE TAKE
IT WRONG.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES HI RAY AS I
AM MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE ARAMBULA.
CHOI.
CHOICE I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I A
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE STONE STONE HI.
WE HAVE THE VOTE COUNT IS SEVEN
TWO ZERO WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU
.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT
VOTE IS SIX TWO ZERO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON I VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM.
ONE SB ONE SEVENTY TWO CURRENT
VOTE IS FOR TO TO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE CURRENT VOTE
[inaudible]
SIX TO TWO FILE ITEM. FOUR SB
TWO EIGHTY FIVE I'M SORRY.
FILE ITEM SIX SB FOUR THIRTY SIX
CURRENT VOTED SIX TO ZERO
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I A GIPSON GIPSON AYE
AYE CURRENT VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM SEVEN SB
FOUR NINETY CURRENT VOTED SIX TO
ZERO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON GIPSON AYE A
CURRENT VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM EIGHT SB
FIVE TWELVE CURRENT VOTED SIX TO
ZERO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I A GIPSON GIPSON AYE
CURRENT VOTE
.
EIGHT TO ZERO NOT A CHANCE --
OKAY
[inaudible]
HI
. FOR AN HOUR THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER -- ON ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SP.
TWO EIGHTY FIVE I DO WANT TO IT
TO CONFIRM THAT YOU HAVE
ACCEPTED AT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
THAT'S CORRECT KIND OF HER THANK
YOU.
I'M NOT SURE I THANK YOU FOR
THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
OF MY POLICIES -- AND THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL
AND I WANT TO THANK ALSO -- THE
FORMER OPPONENTS OF THE BILL FOR
WORKING WITH US -- THIS -- BILL
WILL HELP -- TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE -- PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA -- WHO ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS CAL FOR US CALIFORNIA
RANKS NEAR THE BOTTOM?
OF THE FIFTY STATES IN TERMS OF
THE PERCENTAGE OF ELIGIBLE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY
RECEIVING CALPERS BENEFITS.
A AND THAT FORMS OUR ENTIRE STAY
AND HARMS MANY LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS OF OUR STATE -- THIS
BILL AND A VARIETY OF WAYS
INCLUDING BY REQUIRING OVERTIME
A TELEPHONIC -- APPLICATION
ACCESS AS WELL AS SENDING SOME
AGGRESSIVE GOALS AND MAKING
OTHER STREAMLINED IMPROVEMENTS --
WILL INCREASE THE PERCENTAGE ARE
OF OF PEOPLE WHO WERE ABLE TO
ACCESS CAL FRESH I WANT TO THANK
OUR ENTIRE COALITION WHOSE WORK
SO HARD ON THIS BILL -- AND I
WANT TO THANK THE WELFARE
DIRECTORS AND I SEE ARE YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AIBO
AND WITH YOU TODAY TEST OF OUR
TREES HE PATTERSON FROM
CALIFORNIA TO POLICY ADVOCATES
AND RUSSELL RAWLINGS DIRECTOR OF
ADVOCACY SERVICES.
AT RESOURCES FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING THANK YOU THANK YOU FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE.
I THANK YOU TRACI PATTERSON
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
ALSO GRATEFUL FOR CENTER WINNERS
LEADERSHIP AND TRULY WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR COMMITTEE AND
STAFF FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK ON
THIS REALLY APPRECIATE IT -- AND
SO ASSN WIENER SAID ON WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS
REALLY SHIFT -- MOVING
CALIFORNIA FROM THE BOTTOM OF
THE NATION TO HOPEFULLY THE TOP --
WE KNOW THAT WE CAN DO IT WE
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY EXPANDED
MEDICAL TO BE NUMBER ONE IN THE
NATION -- AND AS WE HAVE LOOKED
ACROSS THE BOARD WE ALSO SEE
THAT IN CALIFORNIA OUR RATES OF
POOR ACCESS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT SOME PEOPLE -- ONLY 20%
OF ELIGIBLE SENIORS ARE ROLLED
AND CAL FOR ASH -- AMONG THE
WORKING POOR IT'S ABOUT 60%.
I'M IN STATES LIKE NEW YORK AND
FLORIDA THE ALSO HAVE A VERY
DIVERSE POPULATION SEE UPWARDS
OF 90% SOME STATES THAT ARE
ACTIVELY IMPOSING WORK
REQUIREMENTS TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT ALSO HAVE PARTICIPATION
OVER 90%.
I'M SO WE KNOW BY WORKING
TOGETHER WE CAN DO BETTER AND I
JUST WANNA SAY THERE'S BEEN A
REALLY POSITIVE SHIFT IN CAL
FRESH WITH THE STATE AND THE
COUNTY IS REALLY ENGAGING
STAKEHOLDERS TO WORK TOGETHER
AND THAT'S BEEN AMAZING IT'S
BEEN REALLY POSITIVE -- BUT ALSO
EVEN WHEN WE WALK OUT OF THOSE
MEETINGS FEELING REALLY GOOD.
UNLESS THOSE MEETINGS TURNED
ACTUAL ACTION SO THAT WERE
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PEOPLE WE
HEAR FROM THOSE GOOD MEETINGS
DON'T MEAN VERY MUCH -- AND SO
WHAT SB TWO EIGHTY FIVE DOES IS
REALLY PUT SOME ACCOUNTABILITY
TO THE PEOPLE WE ALL SERVE -- SO
THAT I DON'T HAVE TO GO OUT AND
HERE AGAIN FROM AN ELDERLY WOMAN
LIVING IN THE GARAGE WHO IS
SCARED TO GO TO THE WELFARE
OFFICE BECAUSE A REGISTRATIONS
LAPSED OR A SINGLE MOM AND SAN
DIEGO.
WHO'S TRIED TO APPLY THREE TIMES
AND IS NOW TRYING TO SAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO MOVE TO ARIZONA ON
THESE ARE STORIES THAT I CARRY
WITH ME AND REALLY CARRIED AWAY
ON ME AS I DO MY ADVOCACY
BECAUSE I ALSO HAVE BEEN ON FOOD
STAMPS IN THE PAST MYSELF.
AND I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE AND I
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO ACTUALLY
GET THE HELP THAT ALLOWS YOU TO
MOVE FORWARD AND SO I REALLY
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
WORK AND MOVING THIS FORWARD --
IT'S A REALLY BIG MOMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA SHOULD AND I HOPE
THAT WE TAKE THAT STEP FORWARD
AND EVEN MOVE AHEAD OF THE
DEADLINES THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED
IN THIS BILL THROUGH PURE
LEADERSHIP FROM THE COUNTIES.
THANK YOU THANK NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RUSSELL RAWLINGS I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY SERVICES AT
RESOURCES FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING.
WE ARE THE INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTER SERVING PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES IN SACRAMENTO AND
YOLO COUNTY AND WE'RE A PROUD
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIANS FOR
SSI COALITION -- TODAY I'M HERE
TO TELL YOU -- MY EXPERIENCE --
PARTICIPATING WITH THE COALITION
IN THIS PROCESS -- WE HAVE BEEN
I'M VERY PROUD TO BE A PART OF
THE CDSS STAKEHOLDER
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS.
AND FROM THE VERY BEGINNING THE
STRATEGY WAS TO DEVELOP A CALL
CLICK OR COME IN APPROACH.
AND WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT -- THIS
WILL -- THIS ACTION WILL ENABLE --
THIS FULL IMPLEMENTATION FOR ALL
COUNTIES -- MANY TIMES A LACK OF
PHONE ACCESS PRESENTS BARRIERS
TO PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES THAT
CANNOT GET TO THE PHYSICAL
LOCATION.
ARE MAY NOT HAVE DIGITAL ARM --
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY SPECIALLY
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES -- WE
REALLY HOW I'M I HAVE ENJOYED
PARTICIPATING IN THE STAKEHOLDER
PARTICIPATION PROCESS BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE WORK IS NOT
DONE UNTIL IT'S DONE IN THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
SO WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT YOU --
CONSIDER THE STATE AS YOU MAKE
YOUR DECISION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES SUPPORT.
JEFF TOWARD AGUIRRE.
ADVOCATE AND IS BEING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY COALITION AND
STAKEHOLDERS THE LAST YEAR TO
GET THIS GOING.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
GET CLEANED UP.
THANK YOU.
CHRIS RICH WALLOW WITH A. R. P.
REPRESENTING THREE POINT THREE
MILLION MEMBERS THE STRONGLY
SUPPORTS.
THANK YOU.
MAY DAVIS M. AT THE SAN
FRANCISCO MARIN FOOD BANK IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DANIEL SERVING -- ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES -- THIS
IS A REALLY NEW OPPORTUNITY TO
CONNECT PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TO
THIS VERY VALUABLE SERVICE
REGIONAL CENTERS LOOK.
FOR TO ADDED THIS LIST OF
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE SERVICES THEY
CAN CONNECT THIS POPULATION.
TO Q. I REMIND THE REST OF THE
WITNESSES.
JUST WANT THE NAME AND
AFFILIATION YES MADAM CHAIR
MISSY JOHNSON HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY FOR
NUTRITION AND DIETETICS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER RUN
REPRESENTING NEXT AND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I HAVE A CONTRACT ON BEHALF THE
NATIONAL SO HE HAVE SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
PAUL TOWERS ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS AND FARMER'S SKILLED IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
FILL THE RACE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
OF THE BLIND IN SUPPORT.
CARE FOR EARLY CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU BOTH.
CASSIDY CARMEN BATES FOOD BANK
OF CONTRA COSTA AND SOLANO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AMY D'ERLON RIVER CITY FOOD BANK
HOW FRESH OUT REACH DIRECTOR.
IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KERR CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND A CHAIN -- PRESENTING FOOD
BANKS ACROSS THE THE STATE IN
STRONG SUPPORT REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THE RICH WHICH IS COMPRISED
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CAPITAL HERE TO GIVE VOCAL
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS CA FOR
HEALTH CALIFORNIA FOOD FARM
NETWORK CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES.
COMMUNITY CLINIC ASSOCIATION OF
LA COUNTY COMMUNITY HEALTH
COUNCILS ECOLOGY CENTER.
FOOD CHAIN WORKERS ALLIANCE.
HUNGER ACTION LOS ANGELES.
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES OF LA.
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA.
LONG BEACH LANCE FOR FOOD AND
FITNESS.
ELLIE FOOD POLICY COUNCIL.
PACIFIC COAST FARMERS MARKET
SOCIAIS SHIN SAID ANTHONY SAN
FRANCISCO AND SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMIC ENTERPRISES OF LOS
ANGELES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IT'S JUST ME DESK OF ART LOW
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY ADDING ON AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
LIBBY SANCHEZ AS HE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION PREVIOUSLY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU -- VERY VERY MUCH -- TO
COMMITTEE STAFF TO THE CHAIR OF
THE AUTHOR -- FOR WORKING
TOWARDS BEING ABLE TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION OPPOSITION WAS NEVER
PROMISED ON THE UNDERLYING
POLICY WITH WHICH WE ALL AGREE
BUT RATHER ON THE INABILITY FOR
COUNTIES TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
SUCH SWEEPING SYSTEMIC CHANGE.
SO IMMEDIATELY -- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND STAKEHOLDERS NEXT
YEAR TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
ADEQUATE RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
COUNTIES AND THE WORKERS THAT I
REPRESENT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WHEN TELEPHONIC
IMPLEMENTATION IS IMPLEMENTED
THAT IT WORKS BEST FOR THE
WORKERS AND THE CONSUMERS THAT
WE SERVE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KATHY CENTERING AT THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
ALSO WITHDRAWING OPPOSITION
AGAIN THANKS TO THE SENATOR HIS
SPONSORS AND STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE BILL WHEN
IT IS IN PRINT WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS -- AND AGREE WE'VE
GOT WORK TO DO -- TO IMPLEMENT
ASSUMING IT'S FINE AND WE'RE ALL
ASSUMING THAT AND ABLE TO LOOK
FORWARD TO DOING THAT WITH ALL
INCLUDED THANK YOU.
SENATOR WINNER I WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS IT WAS --
ENGAGING -- IS THAT YOU'VE
ENGAGED ALL OF THE STAKE HOLDERS
AND AND OF THE COMMITTEE AS WELL
AND I SINCERELY APPRECIATE THAT.
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
CALIFORNIA SHE IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT -- WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
THIS FIGHT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS ACTUALLY
APPLY AND RECEIVE THE BENEFITS.
BUT I ALSO.
LIKE YOU WANT TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COUNTY AND WORKFORCE PARTNERS
HAVE THE NECESSARY TIME.
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT REQUIRED
TO ACHIEVE THE GOAL AND I THANK
YOU FOR TAKING EVERYBODY INTO
CONSIDERATION AS YOU -- TOOK
YOUR AMENDMENTS AND OFFERED
AMENDMENTS AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS BANKING
ANALYSTS THANK YOU LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS QUESTIONS MISTER MATHIS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
CENTER I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS WE ALL
KNOW YOU AS SOMEBODY THAT.
ISN'T AFRAID TO TACKLE THE TOUGH
ISSUES AND WORK WITH EVERYBODY
AND GET THE AMENDMENTS DON --
CAL WORKS IS A GREAT PROGRAM AND
CAL FRESH.
LONG DAY WERE ALL THERE -- AREA.
BUT THESE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
NEEDED -- ESPECIALLY IN OUR
DISADVANTAGES COMMUNITIES --
ESPECIALLY DISTRICTS LIKE MINE.
SO I APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK ON
THIS I'D LOVE TO ADD ON AS A CO
AUTHOR WITH UP TO HAVE IT THANK
YOU THANK SOMEONE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT TO HAVE MOTION AND
SECOND PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES HI RAY AS I
AM MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I'D
CHOI.
CHOICE I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I A GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
STONE STONE AYE.
THE CURRENT VOTER SEVEN ZERO
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MY ONE AND TWO OKAY YES LET'S
ADD MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM TO SB TWO NINETEEN
CURRENT VOTED SEVEN TO ZERO
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I FINAL VOTE
[inaudible]
EIGHT TO ZERO ALL RIGHT.
A RUSTLE THIS CONCLUDES OUR
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE HEARING
[inaudible]
THE